The Joe Rogan Experience how many times
the dude come up to you went insane in
the membrane oh man
it's almost every almost almost where
everywhere we go if I catch eye contact
and sometimes if I don't catch eye
contact they'll wait for me to walk by
and they'll and then they'll they'll
they'll sing it or they'll or they'll
call me Cypress yo Cyprus
that's been my name in New York for a
long time yo Cypress because sometimes
they don't know the all of our names
they but they they know what group we're
in so you know they won't say hey be
real or doctor great yo Cypress that's
cracking that's kind of awesome though
yeah I got a lot of names
[Laughter]
man I remember when you guys first came
out I was like this is a totally new
kind of sound like you guys had a
totally new kind of sound I remember I
found out about it like I wasn't even in
the weed back then I was like why is
this weed symbol everywhere what are
these guys doing these rappers with weed
what the hell's happening over there but
uh I remember listening I'm like this is
you guys had a completely different kind
of sound
yeah you know the thing was is that mugs
was from New York it was from flushing
so a lot of his influence was from New
York you know his favorite production
was like the bomb squad which we're
producing Public Enemy and all their
[__] they had like some of the most
complex production at the time with
Bridges and breaks and these crazy
sounds and stuff like that so you know
that's what mugs got down with now when
he moved out here and we we start
hanging out he's introducing us to New
York music you know hip-hop music that
we we heard we heard some of it via the
radio on KDAY AM station it was playing
a lot of uh hip-hop in the mix and some
of it uh mixed with r b and sold
throughout the day so this is where we
got our first introduction to hip-hop
but mugs being from New York whenever
we'd go back he'd come back with new
records and he'd introduce us to stuff
like that and so when it came time to to
to working on an album
he had all that influence and you know
being from New York and absorbing all
that culture it sounded sort of like New
York style production
mixed with a little bit of La influence
especially with you know what sen and I
were kicking in terms of vocals because
we were using a combination of LA and
New York slang you know merged as one so
that's why a lot of people were confused
like where are these guys from you ask
people in New York they thought we were
from East New York and they were from
Cypress Hills New York and people that
that were from La they were like well
wait a minute they kind of sound West
coast-ish I think they're from out here
but they didn't really know until we
came out and said you know yeah we're
from LA
are boys from New York and we're sort of
a bridge you know between LA and New
York with the sounds so yeah it was
always a a New York influence sound
because I mean that's where it was from
but I think that that's what added to us
being different because most things that
were coming out of Los Angeles in that
time or Southern California
sounded like gangster rap sounded like
uh you know uh a version of NWA or
Compton's most wanted or something like
that
and we didn't we wanted to be different
we didn't want to be in that lane you
know we felt that was their Lane we need
to make our own so we didn't want to
sound like anything
else that was in Cali we didn't get
signed by a California label like
whether it was Sony or any of it we got
turned down here because we didn't sound
like we were from from California yeah
and how short-sighted people are and it
turned out that like our our uh well we
call him Uncle Joe Joe the butcher who
was based out of Philly
but he had you know his label with
roughhouse with uh Chris Schwartz he he
had worked with mugs on a on an album
that when mugs was in a group called 783
he knew mugs's potential he liked mugs
he saw that you know he was evolving as
a producer he heard about our thing and
he wanted to take a chance on us where
we were getting turned down from every
goddamn label in in La they just they
just didn't understand us so you guys
are talking about weed
how does this make sense what have you
got any other songs we're like no we're
cool and yeah we I want to get high
you're sitting there they're eating much
listening to a song about getting high
they're like what the [__] is this
um or no we didn't even have that song
yet it was we were talking about uh it
was uh the get high song on there was
um light another and something else but
light another was a main one and we're
talking about it that's one of the demos
that played and
you know that you could see the execs
just scratching their head like what do
we do with this I mean like isn't it
funny that everybody wants everything to
be cookie cutter yeah like the idea that
rap didn't even exist a few decades
prior right it wasn't even a common
thing and now all of a sudden it's huge
and they can't see that maybe there's
another branch of this that could I mean
it's funny that they wouldn't be they
wouldn't recognize how good it is that's
what's weird what it is is they don't
want to take a chance on trying to
develop it because if it fails it's on
their back yeah you know what I mean so
they want something that's easy that
like oh it's this sounds like this we
can Market it in this Lane this is
already a successful template let's use
this oh they're not using that [__] we
can't do nothing with it so you know
like it's the development and
fortunately you know when we got
assigned to roughhouse Colombia we had
the power of of of Colombia backing us
up because they sort of believed in what
what we were doing well they'd not sort
of believed they believed in what we're
doing and got behind it and allowed us
to be as creative as we wanted to be and
and pushed us and and uh you know along
with having Joe and Chris on our side
creatively like pushing our line and
saying hey with these guys are doing
great we don't want to intervene and you
know change anything they're doing just
let them [__] go
I mean that was everything because you
know most the time they want an easy
layup so if let's just say you know
there's a group over here that's doing
well hey how come why don't we make a
record like this over here right it's
like well why don't you go sign that
[__] over there this is not who we are
so you know they want you to make it
easy but realistically it's no nothing
good is ever easy you got to work toward
it and develop it unfortunately you know
we got on the team that that believed in
that and man it was the biggest [__] you
to all those that turned us down and
didn't get what we were doing uh they
got it now y'all got it now right you
got it now